organic chemistry is based on carbon
containing molecules with CH bonds so
some joke that organic chemists see the
entire periodic table as carbon except
for a few other key elements now the
stereotype kind of makes sense
organic chemistry arose as a discipline
to describe the chemistry of life and
the elements contained within the human
body are concentrated in this upper
right portion of the periodic table but
if we're talking about biochemistry
there are other elements that are
important as well trace elements in the
human body include the transition metals
and many of the reactants that you'll
meet in organic chemistry 1 & 2 span the
entire periodic table all that being
said I'm going to give into stereotypes
for a moment and we're going to focus on
the bonding of elements in the upper
right-hand portion of the periodic table
because these are the most likely
elements to be bonded to carbon in
organic molecules let's briefly review
the octet rule most elements like to
have eight electrons around them
this includes all of the electrons that
are shared in bonds there are many
exceptions to this of course and a
notable one is hydrogen which only makes
one bond and therefore has two electrons
around itself if you're not allowed to
use a periodic table to complete your
exam it's wise to memorize the periodic
table going over from carbon to fluorine
and down the halogens you can use my
silly acronym can normal owls fly or
come up with your own going from left to
right the number of valence electrons
that the element prefers to have
increases and now we get to our little
trick starting with carbon we can count
down from four and we get the number of
bonds that the element likes to form
when it is neutral
now phosphorus and sulfur also follow
this rule but they're special cases
because they have empty D orbitals they
can actually exceed an octet of
electrons around them so phosphorus when
neutral will form either three
we're five bonds and sulfur can form two
four or six bonds to other atoms when
neutral let's look at a simple example
of a molecule containing an element from
each group so we can correlate the
number of valence electrons with a
number of bonds that the element likes
to make here I've drawn out methane with
a pair of dots to represent the two
electrons that are shared in the bond to
hydrogen in organic chemistry it's more
conventional to show the pair of
electrons as a single line connecting
the two atoms keep in mind that each of
these lines is representing a pair of
electrons now to count valence electrons
we can think about splitting the bond in
half and thinking carbon owns half of
the electrons in each bond since carbon
likes to have four valence electrons
carbon is neutral in methane now let's
move on to ammonia nh3
we see that nitrogen likes to make three
bonds when it's neutral and we have
three bonds to hydrogen in the structure
of ammonia
however nitrogen likes to have five
valence electrons and we only have three
coming from bonds this is because
nitrogen contains a lone pair when an
atom has a lone pair you count the lone
pair as belonging just to that atom
itself and so we have five valence
electrons on nitrogen we can look at the
structure of water to explore the
valence of oxygen oxygen is neutral when
it makes two bonds so bonded to these
two hydrogen atoms we have a neutral
molecule of water but its valence is six
this is because oxygen has two lone
pairs so in water oxygen is the owner of
four electrons from lone pairs and half
of the bonds to hydrogen that's six
valence electrons for our fluorine
example we're going to look at
hydrofluoric acid this is a weak acid
but a really toxic molecule fluorine
likes to make one bond when neutral but
it also likes to have seven valence
electrons
so fluorine gets three lone pairs this
gives it six electrons in lone pairs
plus one from the bond to hydrogen this
is seven valence electrons if we
simplify our periodic table even more to
remove the left and the right hand
groups we can come up with a trick to
figure out the formal charge on an
element the number of bonds the element
likes to form when neutral is still
written across the top of a table now if
the element is making one extra bond it
is going to be positively charged and if
it's making one less bond it's going to
be negatively charged let's look at
water once again as our neutral example
water wants to have six valence
electrons and it has four coming from
the lone pair and two coming from bonds
the hydronium ion is a better way to
represent H+ or a proton in an acidic
solution now we have three bonds to
oxygen but we don't want to break the
octet rule we still only want to have
eight total electrons around our central
element so now oxygen has only one lone
pair and a formal positive charge on
oxygen
okay let's count our valence electrons
to see how we figure this out we already
said we have six valence electrons in
water
now with the hydronium ion we have two
electrons coming from lone pairs we also
have three electrons coming from the six
electrons that are shared in bonds
remember oxygen owns half of the
electrons in the bond if we add this up
we see that oxygen has five valence
electrons total well this is one less
negative charge than the six valence
electrons it likes to have when neutral
so if we have one less negative one less
electron oxygen has a formal positive
charge all right so we looked at an
example where oxygen is making three
bonds one extra bond and therefore has
positive charge let's look at an example
where it's making one less bond and has
a formal negative charge
hydroxide is a deprotonated form of
water that exists in basic solutions
let's count electrons we have just one
electron coming from the bond to
hydrogen oxygen is only sharing
electrons in one bond so to complete its
octet we need to add three lone pairs
with the one electron from the shared
bond and the six electrons from lone
pairs we get seven valence electrons on
oxygen this is one more electron than
oxygen likes to have when neutral if we
have one extra negative charge we get a
formal minus charge on oxygen let's
return to our original piece of the
periodic table for a moment that we were
looking at this formal charge trick
works for all of the elements in the
middle three groups so it will work for
nitrogen and phosphorous oxygen and
sulfur and the halogens but it doesn't
work for carbon let's see why Carbon
likes to have four groups around it I'm
going to label these groups are this is
a convention used in organic chemistry
when we don't want to specifically
define what the group is now if we think
about losing our but leaving its
electrons behind on carbon we get an
extra lone pair on carbon
this gives carbon five valence electrons
therefore the atom carries a formal
negative charge now if we think about
carbon ionizing by losing the R group
with a pair of electrons we get a
different story
carbon now has just three valence
electrons it wants to have four so it's
missing one negative charge and it takes
on a formal positive charge itself this
species is called a carbo cation and it
also has three bonds so you can see why
our formal charge trick doesn't quite
work with carbon in this lesson we
looked at the valence of atoms that are
most likely to be bonded to carbon in
organic molecules we looked at some
simple examples and figure
how to determine how many lone pairs are
on each atom we also looked at a trick
for figuring out formal charge on the
groups to the right of carbon and saw
why this trick can't be applied to
carbon itself we'll look at the bonding
of many more elements and practice lewis
structures in another lesson KP here if
you learn something give me a thumbs up
on the way out and for more chemistry
subscribe to my channel